you wanted to see me captain
my husband's dog cheddar had relations
with a neighbor dog karate and produced
these two smaller dogs he insisted that
i find them a good home with someone we
trust
you can trust me dogs are my whole life
also work
doing work and hanging with dogs that's
my lifestyle
you're allergic to dogs aren't you nope
i just need an epipen because my
happiness is making my throat close up
hand me the small dog santiago
look i know that dog meant a lot to you
so i got you this
it's a dog
his name's arlo but you can call him
jason too or whatever seriously i can't
just replace jason with some other dog
why not all dogs are basically the same
watch this arlo go hump that toy
get away from that
that's jason's
look man
i've been patient but we have a case we
need to work on it's time for you to get
over it move on move on
move on
jason was part of my family rosa i loved
him his humping was the only thing that
got me through my divorce seeing him so
happy made me believe that i could be
happy one day too
you wouldn't understand this because you
have a motorcycle helmet for a heart but
i need to feel this sadness so the only
thing that i'm moving on from is you
so i like have a dog now
what is this it's a funeral for jason
i'm gonna say a few words
when jason died seven days ago i didn't
give a rat's ass this is your speech
cause i didn't understand why people
care so much about their dumb dogs until
i got a dumb dog myself
i've only had arlo for a day and a half
but if anything happened to him i would
kill everyone in this room and then
myself
very violent eulogy i like it charles
i'm sorry you don't have to get over it
take as long as you want scully it's
time
sergeant i'd like you to meet richard
and dan they are puppies
very cute sir maybe your twins would
like some little furry friends
i'm sorry sir but that's impossible with
the twins learning how to walk chaos
reigns at the jeffords household i can't
let those innocent pups into that mad
house terry won't do you like that i
understand
just know you have disappointed
all three of us
that's cold sir
traffic is shut down civilians are being
funneled to checkpoints good i just wish
my guys over here could be a little more
efficient yeah i'm looking at you
detective fuzzy paws this is amy hates
dogs amy or amy extra stress damn it's
both amy's i'm under a lot of pressure
and also that dog is a piece of trash
okay until something else is going on
you don't have to pretend to be mad at
the dog first of all i'm not pretending
that dog sucks also
my period's late i think i might be
pregnant oh damn i can't be pregnant
jake and i agreed to wait at least a
year until we tried i haven't found a
nope i'm not on any preschool waiting
list and i spent all of yesterday in a
room with hitchcock in his new cologne
which can't be good for the baby it is
literally called zika okay relax you're
probably not pregnant it's entirely
possible hitchcock's cologne disrupted
your cycle right yes that is a very real
possibility santiago what's going on
here is everything okay yeah totes
right rosa uh totes
why is everyone being all weird today
let's get back to work and be normal yes
sir we'll do we'll be normal nothing to
stress about here
hey fuzzy paws i'm paying you to work
not lick your butthole yeah i'm gonna
get your pregnancy test
look i'm sorry but you have to stay in
the car that's a mistake my super senses
are a tool you can't afford to leave in
the tool chest take me out of the box
and put me on your belt i'm sorry but
you'd only slow us down
and that's exactly what cheddar wants
that's right
i'm on to you you slippery little
bastard
all right everyone listen up here's
where we're at bad news cheddar is still
at large
and you know that slippery little
bastard is just laughing at us
[Music]
that man took a bullet for this precinct
he's a guy who's always looking for love
and friendship and he needs it now more
than ever but you all turned your backs
on him
and you should all be ashamed of
yourselves
i'm sorry those puppies are so cute
they do undercut your tone a bit sir
but on the plus side i think i know what
to do with her
detective
boyle i think you might be able to give
these dogs a good home
you are off the scooter if you have
fallen please call a doctor i don't know
captain i don't know if i should okay
oh
and tickles
they like me so much
are you crying santiago
i'm so allergic can you tell the scooter
to call an ambulance
why are you upset with me your employees
are the ones putting a damper on the
party they are acting terribly you're
the one who's been acting terribly
tonight you've been cured and snobby
with my guests you've been needling poor
peralta so much you practically made him
a new suit
needled him a new suit even when we're
fighting you're hilarious stop it
stop it
oh no
dog allergies
grab the dog
[Music]
look at me
do not
blow this for us
you know what i knew this wasn't going
to work it never has we should have just
gone out for dinner to a restaurant like
we do every year why did you make me
invite them i made you invite them
because i like them they're good people
santiago are you hiding in my bathroom
with a dog that you're deathly allergic
to
no
[Music]
occupied
okay then wash my dogs and be warned
they just watched peabody in german so
they're extra horny
[Music]
yeah
jason wait your turn
lauren scully how was your weekend
it was fun kelly and i hit the park went
for a long walk fell asleep watching tv
wow sounds like a fun weekend with kelly
so
kelly is that scully's wife or his dog
uh
wait no one knows scully's wife's name i
think kelly is his dog went for a long
walk that's what you do with a dog you
can go on a long walk with a person
at sunset talking about nothing and
everything sounds awful hit the park
that's a dog my wife takes the babies to
the park all the time
all right we're doing this let's play
wife or dog
hey so scully what do you do at the park
with kelly oh we just walk around she
gets antsy if she doesn't get outside
enough and then it's just yeah yeah all
day long
hey what's kelly's favorite food peanut
butter she'll eat it right out of the
jar how old is kelly again well she's
getting up there but she's pretty spry
for her age especially considering she
got hit by that car a year ago oh that's
so awful was she chasing something into
the street or nah
just getting me in the newspaper all
right this is useless scully is kelly
your wife or your dog how can you ask me
that
i still don't know which it is it could
be either i have to grab some fresh air
[Music]
good boy cheddar bring me that
[Music]
caramel wait a minute
this isn't the championship cummerbund
this is some common cummerbund
you're not cheddar this is some common
[ __ ]
you